Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir machen Podcast. Also Salon heute. Heute ist Salon.
Heute ist Salon. Wir sprechen über das Buch Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet von Richard David Precht. Das ist ja ein Thema, das uns jetzt schon seit Monaten verfolgt in diesem Podcast.
Wie findest du das Tier da vorne drauf?
Ja, was ist das für ein Tier? Das ist ein Axolotl und das hat selbstredend was mit dem Buch zu tun.
Ist aber noch keine Larve. Es gibt ja verschiedene Tierstadien, die uns gleich vorgestellt werden. Ein bisschen mehr als eine Larve.
Ja, genau. Aber wir sind so eine Axolotl-Gesellschaft, offenbar. Wir schauen uns an, was das bedeuten kann.
Also ich bin kein Axolotl, Richard. Okay, warte.
Aber du bist ja nicht unzufrieden mit dem Buch an sich, oder?
Also, das Buch kommt sehr nah ran an die Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Ja.
Hegemon, wer ist Herr Hegemon? Wer bestimmt hier, wer sich für was, wo rechtfertigen muss und so weiter. Und ich möchte es ihm nicht verübeln, dass er natürlich über die Stränge schlägt. Wir sind weder eine Generation noch ein Milieu ökonomischer Natur. Deswegen sieht er naturgemäß Sachen anders. Aber noch eine Unterscheidung. Ich bin Ossi, er ist Wessi. Der Ausspruch, uns fragt ja keiner, den kenne ich von vor 20 Jahren aus dem Osten.
Genau, außerdem gibt es auf der Webseite verlinkt das Salon Archiv. Es sind jetzt alle Salons aufgeführt mit allen Kapitelmarken und oben gibt es ein Suchfeld. Ihr könnt also nach Tuus suchen, steht da, zwölf Erwähnungen. Und dann sind genau die, wo Tuus auch vorkommt, unten aufgelistet. Also da kann man sich jetzt endlich Übersicht verschaffen. Das wird es natürlich für den allgemeinen Podcast auch noch geben, aber da will ich natürlich gleich eine KI-Suche, deswegen muss ich da noch ein bisschen Vibe coden. Ich rufe da auch nochmal nach Hilfe auf, spezifischer Hilfe, denn es ist gar nicht so einfach, die großen Kapitel, die großen Podcast-Transkripte in diese kleinen Chunks einzuteilen, sodass man überhaupt da drauf zugreifen kann, weil keine KI kann 50 fünfstündige Transkripte durchsuchen. Also da stoßen alle an ihre Grenzen. Aber zumindest die Salonsuche gibt es schon mal. Also für alle, die schon Salonmitglieder sind, die können einfach sich die Sachen raussuchen. Die Texte sind ja verlinkt. Also man kann direkt den Text anklicken, den wir gelesen haben und kommt dann unten auf die Steady Seite, in der man unsere Besprechung findet.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.